[Applauso]
[Musica]
1930 serbe hartley george majnun chi è
costui
allora era uno dei più famosi chirurghi
in inghilterra però fece un piccolo
errore lo fece alla fine della sua
carriera
lascio ai posteri questa sentenza di
certo non possiamo immaginare in futuro
una chirurgia più perfetta di quanto non
lo sia già
oggi siamo alla fine di un capitolo la
possiamo considerare una delle prime fa
chiusa anche se involontarie della
storia della medicina anche perché
capite da allora piccole grandi
rivoluzioni hanno modificato in modo
importante tutta la chirurgia fino a
farla diventare quella che oggi la
cosiddetta chirurgia 4.0
immaginate che pochi anni dopo solo
pochi anni dopo inventano il bisturi
elettrico poi di rete
cos'è l'importante il bisturi lattico fu
un'invenzione fondamentale un bisturi
che taglia e coagula contemporaneamente
pensate quanto emorragie in meno che
allora erano uno dei problemi più
importanti della chirurgia oltre alle
infezioni negli anni settanta dal mondo
sovietico arrivano le struttura trici
meccaniche anche queste hanno
rivoluzionato completamente la chirurgia
delle suturatrici che contemporaneamente
tagliavano e cucivano insieme due tratti
di intestino
capite bene che hanno dato un
completamente rinnovato la chirurgia in
quel momento risolvendo tante tante
complicanze oggi le struttura trici
meccaniche sono addirittura elettroniche
e robotiche misurano lo spi
assessore del tessuto e consigliano il
chirurgo quale carica sia meglio
utilizzare rispetto ad un'altra
ma la vera grande rivoluzione in
chirurgia si ebbe all'inizio degli anni
80 questi due chirurghi che vedete un
ginecologo e un chirurgo generale george
seme filippo moore e sono considerati i
padri della moderna chirurgia
laparoscopica e mininvasiva il primo
eseguendo una endoscopia e quindi
un'esplorazione nell'addome che allora
già si faceva spostò lentamente la sua
ottica verso destra vide l'appendice
dice però si può tirar via e fece la
prima appendicectomia laparoscopica e
filippo muore dopo pochi anni
spostando l'ottica un pochino verso
l'alto e vedendo bene una colecisti
patologica malata disse si può fare ed
eseguì la prima colecistectomia
laparoscopica
voi pensate che questi due chirurghi
furono osannati allora niente di più
sbagliato
questi due chirurghi rischiavano di
essere radiati dall'ordine dei medici e
dalle maggiori società scientifiche di
allora perché tutte le volte che vi è
un'innovazione non solo in campo medico
ma in altri campi inesorabilmente si
compongono due gruppi quelli che sono a
favore e quelli che sono contro servono
tutti e due non è detto che siano
sbagliati perché non tutte le
innovazioni vanno a buon fine sarà
l'efficacia prorompente dell'innovazione
a dare ragione agli uni o agli altri
in questo caso la laparoscopia
cosiddetta fu un vero e proprio tsunami
nella chirurgia e nel giro di poco tempo
si riversò su tutto il mondo chirurgico
mondiale
ma qual è la vera e propria innovazione
della chirurgia laparoscopica
improvvisamente l'attenzione si sposta
dal chirurgo grande taglio grande
chirurgo il chirurgo dalle mani d'oro
sul paziente non è importante quanto io
sia brada è quanto ho risolto un
problema sul paziente devo fare lo
stesso tipo di intervento ma lo devo
fare rispettando il paziente di cui o
cura devo cercare di rispettare la sua
incolumità devo provocargli in meno
dolore meno infezioni meno sanguinamenti
meno complicanze e devo fare in modo che
la mia mio intervento per quanto
complesso esso sia consenta al paziente
di tornare il più rapidamente possibile
alle sue normali attività sociali e
lavorative è un cambiamento epocale
perché da quel momento in poi il
paziente è al centro di tutti i discorsi
medici di qualsiasi specialità il quando
entra un paziente in ambulatorio
molto spesso abbiamo due tipi diversi di
atteggiamento
il primo è dottoressa ma mi opera con i
buchini questo tipo di espressione può
far sorridere ma attenzione perché negli
stati uniti questa chirurgia viene
chiamata che io surgery cioè la
chirurgia dal buco della serratura
l'altro atteggiamento del paziente che
entra e dice ma dottoressa ma se lei mi
apre non è meglio perché alla fine mi
tocca riesce a risolvere meglio il
problema piuttosto che lontano guardando
un video e quello che bisogna spiegare
al paziente perché la tecnologia va
spiegata e che nonostante il chirurgo
con la tecnologia inesorabilmente si
allontani un po dal paziente
l'imaging la visualizzazione ma
soprattutto per la precisione del gesto
aumenta io riesco a fare un intervento
molto complesso allontanandomi dal
paziente ma grazie ad una tecnologia che
mi consente un'alta precisione
la laparoscopia però ha dei limiti dalla
pro scopi causa degli strumenti rigidi
che a volte rendono leggermente più
difficoltoso l'intervento ed ecco che
interviene la chirurgia robotica in che
cosa consiste la chirurgia robotica
vedete il chirurgo è seduto comodamente
in una console appoggia il suo viso su
un visore e da una visione che viene
definita full immersion 3d hd cioè siamo
dentro il corpo del paziente come se
navigassimo al suo interno e si manovra
con joystick e con i pedali un robot che
è come un grande ragno che sovrasta il
paziente a cui sono collegati degli
strumenti che hanno la stessa mobilità
delle mie mani e delle mie dita
quindi è come se io fossi anche se sono
distante lontano dal paziente
all'interno e posso muovere gli
strumenti come le mie mani quindi vedete
console lontana sono in un angolino
della stanza eppure il robot sul
paziente riesce ad avere dei movimenti
estremamente precisi
il robot elimina completamente il
tremore delle mie mani
capite bene che io posso lavorare 10 ore
ininterrottamente
stando seduta e senza avere il minimo
tremore nelle mani il mio gesto sulla
punta degli strumenti diventa più
preciso di sette volte vuol dire che il
mio movimento sul joystick
in questo modo diventa sulla punta dello
strumento più piccolo di sette volte e
quindi molto più preciso ho una visione
ingrandita di 10 volte quindi ad occhio
nudo non potrei mai avere lo stesso
risultato
io con la mia console potrei essere
altrove
potrei essere in un'altra stanza e avere
lo stesso risultato nel 2001
fu eseguita per la prima volta è anche
l'ultima al mondo un intervento
chirurgico un'operazione che prese il
nome di operazione lindberg un chirurgo
situato a new york o però ed eseguì una
colecistectomia robotica in un paziente
a strasburgo
vi lascio immaginare la complessità
nell'organizzare questa intervento che
ovviamente rimase un unico esempio di
fattibilità ma rende ragione anche del
motivo per cui il robot all'inizio
furono inventati soprattutto in campo
militare per permettere di eseguire
interventi anche in condizioni estreme
in territori non facilmente
raggiungibili
pensate a radiazioni o altri o altri
motivi
oggi invece hanno avuto un utilizzo
ovviamente in un mondo pacifico che
respirare speriamo rimanga tale per
molto la chirurgia robotica e alla sua
preistoria
noi siamo stiamo vivendo gli inizi di
un'evoluzione che è già in atto ogni
anno assistiamo sempre di più ad
evoluzioni tecnologiche che porteranno e
stanno portando già alla
miniaturizzazione della tecnologia si
parla già di chirurgia fetale di
chirurgia endocrina le di chirurgia
cellulare e di micro nano chirurgia
ci siamo già ma ovviamente a dovremo
aspettare ancora qualche anno per lo
sviluppo di tutte le tecnologie compresa
la realtà aumentata che verrà trasposta
sulla chirurgia in breve tempo un
articolo pubblicato l'anno scorso
dall'università di oxford apre monizza
toe che nel 2050 3 non mi chiedete
perché 2.053 vanno fatto i loro conti ci
saranno i primi i robot che eseguiranno
autonomamente la loro prima operazione
chirurgica
ora non voglio dire non sarà mai
possibile perché altrimenti nel tè decs
2.053 ci sarà uno che farà vedere
mia foto e dirà nel 2018 c'era una
dottoressa che diceva no no non dico
forse sarà possibile anzi spero che sarà
possibile ma una cosa non potrà mai
mancare e lo cerco di spiegare con un
esempio nel 2010 decisi di eseguire qui
a modena primo intervento in italia la
prima tiroidectomia trans ascellare
robotica e dovevo trovare un paziente è
disposto ad essere il primo il primo in
italia ma anche il primo per me quindi
capite già la complessità di spiegare
l'intervento di come togliere dalla
scena ma tiroide ma anche trovare un
paziente disposto ad essere il primo
arriva questa signora qui dopo un lungo
discorso faccio la sua fede dica domanda
allora signora se la sente di iniziare
con me questo percorso questa avventura
e lei mi guarda e mi dice dottoressa ma
poco importa se me la sento io
lei se la sente
perché se lei se la senta io mi fido
capite bene che questo rapporto di
fiducia che si instaura inevitabilmente
tra un chirurgo e un paziente non ci
potrà mai essere tra un paziente un
robot è un fatto talmente forte talmente
empatico che è indispensabile perché una
parte un paziente affida la sua vita la
sua vita nelle mani di un altro perché
si fida perché gli ha ispirato oltre che
competenza soprattutto fiducia non
esistono rapporti del genere in nessun
altro tipo di rapporti umani a mio
avviso qualcuno mi ha fatto notare va
beh quando salì su un aereo to affidi la
tua vita nelle mani di un'altra persona
che addirittura non conosci il
ragionamento è automatico però
innanzitutto gli affidano un aereo che
costa milioni di euro
bravo dovrà essere ma poi qual è il
ragionamento immediato sull'aereo ci
sale anche lui quindi il rischio almeno
è condiviso
io sotto i ferri ci vado da sola quindi
capite bene che questo tipo di rapporto
medico paziente sara ineludibile la
chirurgia tecnologica un robot si potrà
sempre dovrà assolutamente essere
presente tra un medico e un paziente ma
non potrà sostituire né l'uno né l'altro
concludo con questo con questa locandina
non so se avete mai visto questo
questo film è bellissimo è un film degli
anni 60 è un film in cui vengono
miniaturizzati dei medici tra cui anche
un chirurgo e vengono iniettati in un
vaso sanguigno dovevano fare un
intervento su un paziente hanno tempo
un'ora perché dopo un ora tornano
normali quindi un po di suspense e di
panico c'è durante questo film
poi dopo un viaggio meraviglioso nei
vasi sanguigni nel polmone in tutto il
corpo umano riesco ad uscire
dal corpo umano tramite una lacrima io
quando ho visto questo film avevo 7 anni
e dopo averlo visto ho deciso di fare il
medico
sono andato a da mio padre e gli ho
detto papà da grande farò il medico
avevo 7 anni e lui mi dice bene ma
perché
ma perché papà perché io un giorno
volerò su un globulo rosso
[Applauso]
[Musica]